how about this Dei must diie the point
was to end discrimination not to replace
it with different discrimination you
know it's interesting I think you could
Whittle that in a slightly different way
I kind of think the point of Dei was
actually to put discrimination into
everything he's he's given them he's
like kind of given them the best sort of
outcome of these ideas that what they
these people you know the road to hell
is paid with good intentions these were
good people at these places and these
people want wanted equity and blah blah
blah I actually don't think so I really
don't think so I think the people that
push the people that put diversity
equity and inclusion departments in our
corporations in our government in all of
these places I actually think most of
them actually knew exactly what they
were doing they were instilling racism
they were unearthing old things that we
had put to bed but that's a we're we're
just kind of splitting the difference on
intentions right there let me show you
another tweet from Elon diversity equity
and inclusion are propaganda words for
racism sexism and other isms this is
just as morally wrong as other racism
and sexism changing the target class
doesn't make it right quite correct
right if you just say we will not hire
white people because of equity or we're
going to make sure we don't have that
many Jews around cuz they got it too
good or something like that it's not
Reverse Racism it's good oldfashioned
racism now you're going to love this so
he puts out these tweets and this really
gets us to the heart of what today's
show is all about the director general
of the World Health Organization the wh
his name is Tedros adnam Gabus I think I
pronounced that correctly uh he saw
elon's tweet and he retweeted it and
wrote this and listen this this is the
head of the who do you think this
organization has had a little too much
uh control over our lives after the the
three years of Co check this out Dear
Elon Musk I understand your perspective
but I respectfully disagree I can give
you many examples from my own experience
and from others diversity equity and
inclusion are essential principles that
aim to promote fairness equal
opportunities and respect for all
individuals regardless of their
background or identity perspectives and
experiences these principles are about
creating a more just and inclusive
Society let's work together to make sure
everyone is treated with equality and
dignity Connor leave that up for just a
second because the duplicitous double
language that they're using here so on
one hand he's saying okay diversity
Equity inclusion which we know is based
on judging people by race right like no
one's no one's debating that so he's
saying diversity Equity inclusion are
important and then he's saying respect
for all individuals regardless of their
background or identity except the whole
thing is based on judging people by
their background and identity
so what happens when you put these
really ridiculous backwards racist ideas
into
play